مصر هبه النيل تخشى على حصتها من النهر
الخالد وشريان الحياه مخاطر السد النهضه
الاثيوبي تزيد مقابل تراجع منسوب المياه
عندها
برفض قاطع علقت اديسبب على الاتهامات
الاخيره لوزير الخارجيه المصري لها واللي
قررتها الاحاديه التي قال انها تضر بدول
المصب
اثيوبيا لم تلحق الضرر بدول المصب وهي
ملتزمه بالحوار الثلاثي اتهامات السيد
الوزير خاطئه واثيوبيا ترفضها سنستمر في
استكمال بناء السد لتحقيق اهدافنا
التنمويه اود التاكيد ان النيل نهر افريقي
ويجب وقف تمرير الملف الى مجلس الامن او
الجامعه العربيه والالتزام بحل الخلاف
داخل البيت الافريقي وكان الوزير سامح
شكري طلب ادي سبب بجديه اكبر في المفاوضات
اصبح هناك
ضروره بان تتحلى اثيوبيا بالمسؤوليه في كل
ما تطلع به من
اجراءات الانتهاء من السد نستمر في السعي
للتوصل الى الاتفاق اذا كان هناك اراده
سياسيه حقيقيه حصه مصر الثانويه من مياه
النيل هي اكثر من خمسه وخمسين مليار متر
مكعب ومنذ بدا مشروع
لم تتوقف عن الاعتراض بشان عدم تقاسم
البيانات معها ومع السودان يتزمن السجال
الكلامي الاخير بين القاهره والديسبب ومع
ظهور صور اقمار اصطناعيه عاليه الجوده من
شانها ان ترفع نبره الحرب الكلاميه بين
البلدين تكشف صور مكسار الامريكيه
الانشاءات الجاريه والتعليه في السد
لتجهيزه للتعبئه الرابعه يشار الى ان
المرحله الاولى للملء جرت في يوليو 2020
وخزنت اثيوبيا حينها ما بين اربعه مليارات
ونصف متر مكعب وخمسه مليارات متر مكعب
المرحله الثانيه تمت تقريبا بعد عام من
الملء الاول وكان الهدف تخزين اكثر من 13
مليارا متر مكعب
احتفاله اديسبب بالحدث لم تتبعه حصيله
رسميه للكميه الفعليه المخزنه في المقابل
تحدثت مصادر مصريه عن اخفاق في تلك
المرحله وان التعبئه لم تتجاوز ثلاثه
مليارات متر مكعب المرحله الثالثه كانت في
اغسطس العام الماضي كان الهدف منها تخزين
عشره المليارات متر مكعب تامل وتسع
اثيوبيا الى بلوغ اربعه وسبعين مليار متر
مكعب في نهايه المطاف بقلق وغضب وسجال
دبلوماسي معلن تتابع القاهره كل تفصيله
مرتبطه بصد تعتبر مخاطره اولويه تهدد
امنها القومي بنظر ادي سببا فان السد جزء
من نهضتها وتنميتها الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه وهي تقلل من شان الحديث عن
مخاطره على دول المصب السودان ايضا له
مخاوفه التي تلتقي احيانا مع الموقف
المصري وتبتعد عنه قليلا حسب الظروف
السياسيه والاقليميه ولكن مع التشبس بمبدا
ضروره تقاسم الجاره اثيوبيا بيانات ملء
وتشغيل السد مع الدول المعنيه الاهم الا
تموت فرص حل سلمي لازمه السد فوق النيل